something that previously maybe one
reader in a thousand would have guessed
but you still had the other 999 it would
have no inkling until you reveal it in a
book now that one person in a thousand
puts it on an Internet message board and
everybody sees it and they say oh yeah
yeah that's right no now I see the clues
I got it and pretty soon half the
readership or at least the
internet-savvy portion of your
readership knows it but what do you do
then do you change it and come up with
something goofy and outlandish that you
haven't lead D you haven't done the the
foreshadowing for that you haven't laid
the foundation for just in order to
surprise people I mean sure I could have
like aliens come down and that would
certainly surprise the Hat of everybody
no one is predicting that but it would
ruin the series so
the realm
you
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight video as I'm making this video
today is actually the one year
anniversary of the Game of Thrones
finale it's hard to believe it's already
been a year since Game of Thrones aired
its final episode I seriously have to
thank all of you for sticking by my side
and continuing to watch Game of Thrones
videos when were so far removed from the
series now as you can see by the name of
the video I want to talk about something
that happened during that final season
in my opinion this was one of the many
big mistakes Dan and Dave made when
writing their ending to the show
I do realize this can be a very
sensitive subject for fans because so
many of us were emotionally invested in
the characters I also realize I'm not
the first one to cover the topic but I
still want to let you all know what I
think about it what I say in the video
may upset some of you but all I ask is
for you to wait until the end before you
leave your opinions that way you know
why I feel the way that I do
hopefully it all makes sense by the time
I'm finished now as you all know one of
the most controversial scenes from the
final season was when Arya Stark
defeated the night king the leader and
creator of the White Walkers and the
army of the Dead
I believe game of thorns writers Dan and
Dave made a massive mistake by not
having Jon Snow fight the night king not
only that but I believe they made an
even bigger mistake by not having Jon
Snow kill the night king let me explain
from the opening scene of the opening
episode the White Walkers and the night
King were set up as the main antagonist
of the story this threat had been
looming over Westeros for thousands of
years but the Nights Watch were able to
keep them behind the wall all the way up
until the end of season seven the Nights
Watch and the White Walkers had been
killing each other ever since the first
long night during the Age of Heroes in
fact the whole reason the Nights Watch
was even created was so they could guard
the wall that protects the realms of men
against any and all attacks from the
White Walkers
so when Jon Snow says he wants to join
the Nights Watch in the very first
episode of the show we knew it would
only be a matter of time before he would
come face-to-face with Westeros his
greatest threat
I always welcome on the wall now bastard
was ever refused to see their so take me
with you when you go back John father
will let me if you ask him I know he
will when it finally does happen I think
most of us believed John Snow was
destined to fight the night king in one
versus one combat it really did seem
like they were setting up this ultimate
showdown between John Snow and the night
king however when the night king finally
does arrive in Winterfell the home of
House Stark the show writers had Arya
Stark deliver the fatal blow instead of
John Snow now whether you like this or
not I think it's safe to say that
decisions shocked millions of Game of
Thrones fans around the globe but in my
opinion it did not make sense when you
consider each character's individual
storyline Arya should not have killed
the night king this was not arias
journey nor should it have been her
destination when you go back to the very
beginning Arya goes south to King's
Landing with her sister Sansa and their
father Ned Stark by the end of the
second episode of season 1 Arya begins
to become completely consumed by getting
revenge on those who have crossed her or
her family we have the incident with
Joffrey the butcher's boy and I'm area
which leads to Joffrey Cersei and even
Songza lying about what happened as we
all know Arya was smart enough to get
Nymeria to leave before she was killed
but that did not stop Cersei from having
one of the dire wolves killed for
hurting baby Joffrey then of course
Sandor Clegane kills arias friend the
butcher's boy this is one of the events
that motivates Arya and gives her that
hunger for vengeance this is also one of
the reasons Arya ends up making a list
of names of those she wants to kill this
is Arya story this is what drives her
she once revenge and she constantly
reminds us of this throughout the series
every time we hear her recite these
names
Circe will defray Meryn Trant Tywin
Lannister the red woman
beric Dondarrion now actually think
about all those names she listed these
are all the characters who have hurt
Arya her family or her friends this has
been her story throughout the entire
show even when she goes to the house of
black and white we still hear these
names get mentioned because Arya is
still driven by that revenge she wants
to become an assassin so she can finish
off the list I mean think about it
the very first thing she does when she
leaves the house a black and white is
scratch another name off of that list
she murders Walder Frey
then she heads for King's Landing next
so she can kill Cersei Lannister now we
all know she ends up back at Winterfell
but as you can see this was arias
journey which did continue until the
very end she even tries to kill Cersei
again when everyone does eventually make
it down to King's Landing the only
reason she did not finish off her list
was because Sandor Clegane stopped her
arias story had nothing to do with the
night king the White Walkers or the army
of the Dead
I mean she had no idea they even existed
until Johnson told her about them in
season seven Arya had no connection with
anything happening beyond the wall this
was Jon Snow's story from the very
beginning what do we see Jon Snow do in
the very first episode we see him go
watch a beheading of a man who claims to
have seen the White Walkers beyond the
wall within a few scenes of that
happening we hear Jon Snow say he wants
to join the Nights Watch the band of
brothers who guard the realm from any
attacks by the night king or his army
Jon Snow becomes intertwined with the
night king whether he knows it or not
from the very first episode
this is his journey when Arya is down
south completely consumed by her list
Jon Snow is out beyond the wall
completely consumed by stopping the
night king in his army it's Jon Snow's
dire wolf that finds the severed hand
which leads to Jon getting the very
first kill against the night king's army
Jon says the Lord commanders life by
catching the white on fire and this is
how Jon Snow ends up getting long
a Valyrian steel sword that just so
happens to kill whites and white walkers
all of this is set up in the first
season when we find out the threat
beyond the wall is actually real and how
do we learn about all this through John
snows story think about the very first
time we see the night king in the show
we first see him when he turns crest her
son into a white Walker and how do we
learn Craster's given his sons to the
White Walkers we learned this through
Jon Snow's eyes
so
something's either Jonathan whatever it
was I daresay you'll see it again the
second time we see the night King is at
hardhome when Jon Snow kills one of the
white walkers with his Valyrian steel
sword the night King even watches as Jon
Snow does this it seemed as if the night
King saw Jon Snow as an actual threat
that he might have to take out himself
this led to one of the greatest stare
downs in television history Jon had
finally come face to face with the
leader of the army he was so desperately
trying to stop from invading Westeros
stopping the night king and his army of
the Dead became Jon Snow's main focus
this is why Jon let the wildlings
through the wall this is what led to Jon
Snow's death but it's also what led to
Jon's resurrection by Melisandre you see
he did not care about becoming the king
or anything else all he wanted was to
defeat the night king to save the realm
from the first episode all the way up
until the night King reached Winterfell
Jon's story was connected to the Nights
Watch and their mission to stopping the
darkness from falling over Westeros now
I could list a dozen more examples of
why it was Jon's destiny to stop the
night king but I think all of you
understand what I'm trying to say even
if you don't agree with me the game of
thrones writers Dan and Dave should have
not changed the course of events the
fate of Jon Snow and the night King were
set in motion from the very first
episode but Dan and Dave decided to
retro actively change some of the
foreshadowing in the show so it would
fit their own version of the events they
said so themselves the only reason they
did not have Jon Snow kill the night
King was because they thought it was
obvious we hope to kind of avoid the
expected and Jon Snow has always been
the hero the one who's in the Savior but
it just didn't seem right to us for this
for this moment they knew the fans were
guessing that they wanted to subvert
expectations but the only thing they
subvert it was good storytelling they
tried to make it seem like Arya killing
the night king was foreshadowed in the
third season when Arya Stark first meets
Melisandre this is when Melisandre says
Arya will shut eyes forever and she
specifically mentions blue eyes like the
night Kings this has brought up again in
the final season when arias
or cat melisandre meet again set up many
eyes forever you're right about that
brown eyes green eyes blue eyes they
tried to make it seem like Melisandre
knew Arya was meant to kill the night
king ever since they first met but that
was not the case the first time we hear
Melisandre say this was during season 3
which was released in 2013 but Dan and
Dave did not know they were gonna have
Arya kill the night king until much
later after the long night episode aired
dan and Dave revealed this during the
inside the episode they said they came
up with the idea about three years ago
which would have been roughly 2016 for
god I think it's probably three years
now or something we've known that it was
gonna be Arya who delivers that this was
a big mistake just because fans might
guess your ending does not mean he
should go back and try to change what
some of your foreshadowing actually
meant when Melisandre said Arya would
close eyes forever that was actually
referring to Arya joining the faceless
men and ultimately crossing more names
off her list that's why you hear the
faceless men music during that original
scene this had nothing to do with the
night King but since Dan and Dave later
decided Arya would be the one to kill
the night king they thought it would be
a good idea to make it appear as if this
was always the case but you cannot do
this George our Martin has said so
himself I said well what do I do with
that what do I do with that day yeah
these people have guessed the secret
that I'm gonna reveal in book 6 people
have already guessed that here and to is
just out you really have two choices
there you can ignore it and proceed with
your plan despite the fact that some
people know where you're going or you
can get all panicky and say oh my god
they figured it out I can't let that be
I'll have to change it I'll have to go
in a different direction and I think
some writers do that we hope to kind of
avoid the expected and Jon Snow has
always been the hero the one who's in
the Savior but it just didn't seem right
to us for this
and I think that's always a mistake yeah
you know if you've planned your book
that the butler did it and then you read
an Internet someone has figured out that
the butler did it and you suddenly
change in midstream and it was the
chambermaid who did it then you screw up
the whole book we should get these just
foreshadowing early on and you've got
these little clues you planted now
they're dead ends and you have to
introduce other clues and you're
retconning it's a mess so by doing this
you completely ruin your story and this
was one of the many reasons why season 8
was considered a massive failure now
let's move on to something else I
mentioned at the beginning of the video
like I said earlier another one of their
big mistakes was not letting the night
King fight but the actor who portrayed
the night King actually knows how to
swing a sword the man who wore the night
king costume has been a stunt man for
many years he even choreographed most of
the sword flights in Game of Thrones and
many other movies and television shows
he has been a stuntman for over 33 years
this man knows how to swing his sword
why would you let that kind of amazing
talent go to waste it just doesn't make
any sense
we saw the night King carry around the
magical ice sword for many seasons yeah
we never got to see him get into a sword
fight the one and only time we saw him
swing that sword was when he cut down an
old man sitting in a tree this does not
do the knight Kings character justice
we saw the White Walkers used their
swords many times and it was obvious
they were good but imagine how good the
knight King must have been considering
he was their leader I would like to
think he would have been hard to beat
but we never got a chance to see him
shine why have a veteran stuntman where
the knight Kings costume if they're
never gonna actually let him get into
any fights now I don't know if you
remember this or not but right after
season 8 ended I said it was a shame
that we never saw the night King get
into a sword fight with anyone the actor
had been a stuntman for 33 years and he
had been choreographing the sword fights
on Game of Thrones for many years now
what's really impressive is he is the
same guy that stood in as the dual
wielding Sir Arthur Dayne at the Tower
of joy this man knows how to swing a
sword in fact he is one of the men that
showed all the other Game of Thrones
actors how to swing their swords I still
can't believe the night king did not use
his sword during the
I know battle after they set him up as
the ultimate villain for so many years
in my opinion this actors talents were
wasted on the highest levels the ending
could have been so much better if the
night King was handled with care
but I think I've said enough for now let
me know what all of you have to say
about this do you agree with me or not
leave your thoughts down below I want to
thank each and every one of you for
watching the video in supporting the
channel thank you very much I hope you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]